DRUNKENESS IS ONLY A PLASTIC POUCH OF POWDER
AWAY!
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE FUTURE IS HERE EVERYBODY.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews!
Back in my day, if we wanted to get drunk
we had to carry a bottle of booze through
the snow, uphill...BOTH WAYS.
But now, kids have "Palcohol".
It's a new and improved way to get drunk that
could hit the shelves later this year.
Scientists behind the product have turned
liquid alcohol into a powder that you can
mix with water to make your drink.
Their website reports that they have 6 varieties:
rum, vodka, and 4 types of cocktails.
Last week, the news spread that Palcohol received
its federal approval, causing a mad frenzy....as
you might imagine.
Then a few days later the feds were like OWAIT
JK.
That was a mistake.
Palcohol's parent company said the mistake
was related to how much powder comes in the
bag and that they're going to resubmit them
for approval.
It's worth noting that other countries like
Japan, The Netherlands (of course), and Germany
already have similar products on the market.
But how exactly is liquid alcohol turned into
a powder?
An old patent from the 1970s lets the public
in on Palcohol's boozy little secrets.
First, they dehydrate a vapor-sorbable carbohydrate
base down to a moisture content of less than
1%.
Ideally, this carbohydrate powder is one that
is easily dissolved in water and perhaps has
a little bit of sweetness.
Once it's been dehydrated to the extreme,
the carbohydrate powder is ready to absorb
the ethanol.
Combine in the proper proportions and VOILA!
You have alcohol in powder form.
In order to stay fresh, the powder has to
stay in a sealed container, otherwise the
ethanol vapors will seep out.
Palcohol says that their powders are 58% alcohol
by weight -- which is why it's also highly
flammable.
When you mix it with water, the percentage
is reduced to 12%.
And, FYI, each pouch contains about 80 calories.
Is powdered alcohol the great idea we've all
been hoping for?
Well, it depends who you ask.
I think for most people, regular liquid booze
is probably fine...but it is a solution for
people who want to take it on the go without
carrying heavy bottles.
Think hikers, backpackers, and people who
want to slip it in their drink at lunch.
And speaking of slipping things in drinks:
that's one of my concerns with a powdered
alcohol - it's actually a little easier to
abuse.
In fact, the original Palcohol website MIGHT
be described as WILDLY irresponsible, and
COMPLETELY out of control.
Originally, they openly highlighting the fact
that you can sneak it into concerts or that
-- even though you shouldn't because that's
dangerous kids! -- it CAN be snorted.
And that it'll get you drunk superfast.
Wink wink.
Since the news broke via public records of
the approval, Palcohol added a shiny and professional
new face to their website.
Smart move there.
So folks, is this something you might try
if it regains its approval?
Tell me what you think in the comments and
if you'd like to learn more check out Anywho's
episode on Palcohol, link down below!
Don't forget to subscribe here for more DNews!